welcome everyone to the first ever
chess.com holiday party we're here with
the eight well seven of the Champions
chess tour flying unless one of them is
not here but lucky for us as Santa I
already knew that one of the gifts might
come in in real handy so what we've got
here is a uh is a gift that keeps on
giving for some lucky lady out there
right there we're going to put Magnus
right here in between Maxine and Hikaru
but let me explain the rules real quick
we have eight numbers in here everyone
here is going to pick a number to decide
the order in which they go to choose the
presents in front the present can be
stolen if you like what someone else
gets you don't even have to pick a
present you can just steal their present
from them but once a present has been
stolen twice it is officially frozen you
can never steal that present again at
the end of the game whichever one of you
gets the number one gets to choose
whether to keep your present or make one
final steel to get the gift you want so
I'm going to go around
here I'm going to to take the last
number lot like our fair play you know
judge jury and executioner over here
right hey there you go insert joke who's
number
one okay Maxine bash the gr starts us
off let's do it well I guess this for my
guest look at that I know what you guys
thought you guys thought you were
showing up and every gift was going to
be a joke no it's not that's a Nintendo
switch M play that every day I'm Number
Two okay I have the the best number the
worst number wor are we found worth than
eight oh eight is the second best oh
really yeah cuz eight you get to have
all the information no choice thank
you I got a box okay what's in the box I
have a smaller
box I got airpods wow number three okay
number three here we go are you stealing
no I'm picking this big oh sweater every
white elephant has to have an ugly
Christmas sweater and you're the one who
got it okay all right who's four
[Laughter]
okay show it to the
camera you can cook the night that
what you can bring it back to
friends Denis here we go okay it says
mag
colti show it to the
the croud
owner here we go all right hiar is
shaking shaking bag or is he
stealing who with that
Danny that was not my idea all right I'm
going to have to use this one here I
don't know what it is but I feel like
Magnus might want it certificate of
disposition and Proclamation lord of the
bong Cloud opening okay I'm I'm a lord
of the bong Cloud here we go Wesley I'm
going deal yeah yeah it's hard to choose
I see I see Abby's airpods that's fair
okay airpods have been stolen it's
official game on wait what happens if I
steal his gift who gets to go after that
does Maxim Maxine gets to go and he
can't steal it right back he has to
steal something else well he'll take the
airpods arguing with you don't know that
that maybe he wants the mbow so we have
to keep the game going so I'm taking
your all right okay now this is your
chance you a
niche okay he's rolling the dice he
loves a niche that much okay Dennis
you've been set free so are you really
going to keep that in your flat or are
you going to give it to Anie are you
I'll figure it out you put it you're
putting by your bedroom yeah all right
Dennis what do you think oh you got the
switch okay Dennis loic officially owes
the switch party and he throw them
tonight I guess I'm taking he's taking
the airpod airpods are off the table
which means Wesley you have the power to
choose a new gift steal the an nishe
yeah I'll open a gift I mean I actually
don't know what this one is oh my gosh
what is it are you
kidding oh yeah they night with d you're
you're paying right yeah that's okay
good good thank you and if is kind of
The Unofficial see of CH he is he is it
goes for a lot I'll keep it okay there
we go that's it and that every with our
first ever white elephant brought to you
by chess.com and Anish giri thank you
CEO of chess.com right there you're
really appreciate it I
[Music]
could and